I guess we ready to start right um in
the back ready okay good morning
everyone
yeah that's the CEO welcome to my
session about the secret unit testing
tools no one has ever told you about my
name is dwell helper I'm a consultant
and the software architect I'll get to
write a lot of code usually in C++ or
dotnet Java from time to time I do a
little client work but don't ask me any
question about that and I also mental
and teach developers about how to write
better code what we refer to as
engineering practices unit testing clean
code TDD design patterns you name it I
have been doing that for quite some time
now and I also have a few Pluralsight
courses and one here is a C++ developer
well I have two courses on unit testing
in C++ and mock in in C++ you want my
what want to check them out
also another course in an another lated
topic a SS lambda but that's me and have
a blog at helper code calm were right
about anything I find interesting
usually software related and the Twitter
and L well you can reach me or tweet
about this session or whatever you want
to do with Twitter now that's me what
about you real write code for living
developers okay so all the home C++
developers I saw yeah good for you
dotnet developers okay most of the
examples will be in dotnet but their
patterns and tool apply to all three of
those at least Java developers okay I'll
give you a few tools as well and I don't
know why you came to this session what
you want to get out of it but I can tell
you the reason I'm talking about tools
because basically I find it strange to
talk about tools in any session because
will developers we can probably handle
write code with the text editor and a
lot of good will right but in the unit
testing area I found out that you need
something to help you some additional
help and the reason being is because I
failed with unit testing multiple times
I've tried writing unit tests for my
code at least three times and failed
miserably and each and every time I was
sure I will get it right this time
and each even every time in the end I
ended up deleting all of my tests and
declaring unit testing as a bad idea
and luckily for me somewhere along the
way I had I found some very bright
individuals who taught me the things I
was missing in order to write good unit
tests and that shouldn't be this way
because unit testing is not rocket
science pretty easy
it's item code right and everybody here
know how to write code and yet a lot of
developers don't manage to write good
unit tests and there's a good reason for
that and the reason is that there's not
a lot of good guidance in the unit
testing world you can probably find the
blog post telling you how to write a
unit test using your unit testing
framework of choice but getting from
Dell to a thousand tests that actually
run all every commit doesn't fail just
because you change something trivial in
your code is a bit harder who you lights
Unitas as part of its code okay so you
might agree or disagree but we'll see
and there are a bunch of tools that no
one talks about and this is the reason
we have this session but we'll start
from the Bell back on the tools
everybody knows about right everybody
knows about this tool you might
recognize it as a unit testing framework
right this is an unit those of you in
the dotnet space probably can recognize
and unit and actually it's two tools
because I have here a unit testing
framework and a mocking framework
because if we look up here okay let's do
this like so
this is the first thing the first
capability the interesting flavor cool
give me the ability to mark a bunch of
random methods as a test right you put
something on top and it's a test for now
and the other thing I get out of my unit
testing framework is this guy in the
bottom called desert and this is about
it I won't get anything more and also I
have here a mocking flavor called fake
it easy
whoo he'll writes unit tests without a
mocking framework it's almost impossible
right the idea behind mocking framework
is very simple when you think about it
the idea is that we need to isolate the
test form any external dependencies such
as a database or additional services and
so we use this tool to create a class
essentially that does absolutely nothing
but look exactly like the class I want
to use so in this example I have a
repository which I don't want to run as
part of my test because I don't want to
call an actual database it will take too
long and I need to fill it with data
which will change from test to test and
in a unit test I want to extract remove
that dependency not run it and I do it
by creating a fake object and that fake
object does absolutely nothing I can
call any method L or as long as I follow
several guidelines we change from
mocking framework to mocking framework
and I get a repository as a repository
does absolutely nothing I'll create two
products and I'll tell that repository
that dumb object to return each of those
two instances when called with a
specific argument and that's it so
essentially I mimicked the database in a
very specific part of its functionality
in order to test something completely
different without that repository and
basically what this test does is I'm
testing a shopping cart and I want to
see what happens when I need two items
that I know about from the database and
I want to check that if item a cost 100
and item because 200
your currency of choice then the total
there will be 300 and this is a very
simple unit test and if we go somewhere
else
nothing dotnet we see the exact same
picture anyone recognize this unit
testing framework anyone recognize the
actual language a Java right because the
curly black is in the wrong place right
yeah this is actually the grandfather of
them all this is J unit the first actual
commercial widely used unit testing
framework and it looks exactly like the
previous example the code is the same
I have something to mark the method as a
test they call it annotations in Java
but it's the same as attributes in
dotnet and I have an assert over here
and have a mock in framework and called
mockito which are used to create the
same effect and it's the same test
essentially world by world so the good
news is that if you know how to use one
unit testing framework you can probably
use them all including in C++
this is C++ looks exactly the same
right mark the test here MCOs but other
than that you mark the test create
affect positively set behavior assert
and all of those unit testing framework
essentially derivative of je unit or as
we name them X unit testing framework
not to be confused with X unit which is
a unit testing framework that follow X
unit testing framework guidelines and
all of them look exactly the same
behaved exactly the same there are some
small changes but if you can read one
you can read them all and this idea
hasn't changed much since 2003 we talkin
15 years ago and our code has changed
tremendously since 2003 so and I find it
to be a problem because if you look at a
unit testing framework such as this
badly named because my test is probably
not a good name for your test although
it is my test essentially it's not it
has absolutely nothing to do
with unitest this is a method it has
code inside which I can run when I want
to and I saw developers use unit testing
framework to debug the code they just
write a bunch of code inside put a
breakpoint and debug it and starts fine
because the unit testing framework give
me absolutely no guidelines no warnings
no nothing about what I write between
those curly bracket I can put whatever I
want they're up to and including the
kitchen sink I can write a huge mess
there and the unit testing time will not
kill it will just run the method and
that is a problem because when starting
with unit tests
I used to write code l a lot of code
there following the same guideline I use
in order to write good production code
but unfortunately those are not the same
guidelines you need when you write unit
tests there's a slight difference
between those because a good unit test
doesn't need to follow the same rules
that production code need to follow a
it's simpler and it has a completely
different objective first of all when
writing unit tests the first thing I
want to be able to do is write it as
quickly as I can
right if anyone here ever had to ask his
manager whether or not to write unit
tests you know the answer don't write
because it takes additional time simple
calculation writing just code and
writing code plus unit istic small and
so let's not do that it takes more time
so you want to be able to write your own
test as quickly as you can
the second thing you want from unit
tests is to be readable because those
unit tests when you initially write them
they will probably pass but they will
fail if they'll fill in a week from now
in a month from now or you'll write your
code minding your own business and
someone else's test will fail anyone who
tests to be as readable as possible
because you want to be able to
understand why that test has failed so
unit tests need to be readable and
readability in unit test trump almost
anything else you can think about
because if the test is readable you're
halfway there
unfortunately unit tests enfermo can't
measure readability so it's up to you
you need to know how to write readable
and it's not necessarily the same as
writing readable production code and
finally I don't want to maintain those
tests I don't want to have to update my
tests each time I change something in my
code I just want to find the test
failing when a bug was introduced to the
system and not before
Oh a requirement change but usually when
writing a test because we know the code
without usually writing a test for my
code right and then I want to be able to
keep on changing my code refactoring the
method change the classes change the
method signature add the parameter to my
constructor without needing to go over
the hundred tests and rename them or
change them or update them each and
every time because I guarantee that if
you have to do that you'll stop you the
Zeen unit test by the third time you
need to do that because it's too much of
an it takes too long so as I
said I've been bashing unit testing
framework for the last ten minutes but
some of you who write unit tests
probably have heard about triple-a
arrange act assert right whoever who
held about triple-a quite a few and
that's good because the first time I did
this session there were like two fingers
what is triple-a well that's a guideline
the first of not so many guidelines we
have in unit tests but self which says
that each test should have three parts
in that specific order first is the
arrange part well we set everything up
in order to set up my system my scenario
create all the new instances and set up
my Maki my mocks and whatever else I
need to do then I have the play button
of the test some methods of an event or
a message that will trigger the scenario
I'm trying to test and finally an assert
which usually is called assert in which
I test whatever happened to my system
and if I follow this specific very
simple guideline my test will be
readable easier to maintain and so
one's own this is partly true because
good developer will find ways to mess
this up
and no one in forced me to use a range
at dessert but I am going to use that in
order to explain in each part how can L
I can improve this test by using those
special tools no one talks about we'll
start with the range set it up my method
the problem when you start writing a lot
of unit is you notice something you
duplicate in a lot of code
anyone who vote for unit tests is
probably notice that and this is
physical can cause you physical pain a
developer who writes the sample twice
start to feel bad with himself
you should because you shouldn't
duplicate your code yeah
however in unit test you can because as
I said different rules for unit tests
and production code you can duplicate
your code but you should avoid it as
much as you can because if you need to
change something in this method or the
hundred methods that test the same
specific area then you'll have a problem
because let's look at this test this is
an old project of mine stuck over flow
notifier I wanted to get notification
whenever gets my reputation in Stack
Overflow increased or decreased and so I
got a small program for that this is
actually the Windows Phone version which
you might use if you have a Windows
Phone and and if you do well good for
you
and basically what I do I'll create two
users this is the same user over time
with the same reputation and a user has
a URL and ETA name and so on it was like
a twenty property kind of data class
I'll create the service repository which
used to call stack overflow but it's a
fake one and I want him to return the
user details and digest initialized and
then I'll call load user twice this was
done using a timer in the original
program and I want to make sure that in
the end the color of the numbers that
show my reputation are still white
because the reputation haven't changed
so obviously the next test
all right the reputation will increase
or decrease or something will happen
over time and it's the same test
initially the same tester hotel with
different parameters and it's a pain to
write the same column the same test over
and over and over again and I don't like
that now if you go and Google for ways
to reduce this duplication you'll
probably learn about a specific method
called test setup test initialize
depends on your unit testing test the
framework of choice essentially I can
create a new method this one that will
run before each test and in that method
I can write all of the initialization
all of the arrange and then my tests
become very small and concise and very
nice easy on the eyes basically and
there are a lot of consultants and book
that will show you to do exactly that I
disagree I think that's a bad idea
that's the best practice that's one of
the things that the unit testing
framework shouldn't have my personal
opinion and the reason is that I'm
missing something here right
these methods are written inside the
class and in order for them to work
together I'll need to add a field to
that class that will be shared between
those methods they initialize and all
the tests now depending on your in
testing framework of choice it also
means that you using the same instance
of that field which means that one test
can't affect a different test and then
you get those will things when your test
will fail in the server or in someone
else's machine and you'll run it and it
will pass and then you go well it works
on my machine but it doesn't matter and
then what you left of doing is running
all the tests and then seeing if the
test fails and then just run in half of
them and you play binary search with
your tests until you find which test
effect which tests and this can take a
few hours and it's a pain to do that you
don't want share the logic between a
test you don't need a state between your
tests so that's a bad idea there are the
bad idea is that once it has failed and
you actually reproduce that failure on
you
chin you end up with having your logic
in two separate places the
initialization and the test and then you
play with your Moscow because it go all
the way up well you usually write your
initialization all the way down to your
test and try to understand how one
affects to the other and if you walk in
with extremely talented programmers you
might end up with this this is actual
code a colleague of mine Aleta is
written as you can tell we have five
fields at this time we have an
initialization method as long as
possibly can that does a bunch of things
and then the tests come and you have no
idea what you use in and what you need
and how the hell did I get to this
position we'll handle this later but
there are ways to reduce this
duplication without resulting in with
two different methods huge methods by
the way you know how many tests we'd had
in the end for that specific area of the
code that we needed this big
initialization
can you guess Dan says one so we ended
up paying for a huge unreadable code for
something we didn't really need so what
can we do the first idea is use factor
method exact method I'll take the
creation of that user and put it in the
method that method only care about my
reputation because that's what I'm
testing and I'm done right it's as
simple as that and it will work
unfortunately in the next test I might
discover something which is not
everybody understand what to extract a
method and what's not as a consultant I
get to come to a company tell them all
my bright ideas go away come back after
a week or month and with a one client I
explained out they should extract some
of the initialization into methods went
away came back and saw something like
this and basically this is not fun
they had exactly three methods each of
them with between 10 to 12 parameters
the first one was called in
as the system ii was called test the
system and the last one was called check
that everything is okay because they
over extracted everything because that's
what we do in production code you know
duplicate code you put inside metals and
best classes and whatever and it was
impossible to understand what the test
actually does because they extracted the
important stuff the things I care about
in the test so that's not a good idea
the second problem being that although I
needed only the reputation in one test
in the next test I needed to change my
image as well and then I'd end up with
the number of permutation of parameters
in that class or factory methods and
this is painful very painful very hard
to maintain if you make a small change
you need to change all those factory
methods and you don't want to do that so
if you get to this point you have to
consider other alternatives and the
first of which being the Builder pattern
this is one of the design patterns from
the original design pattern books and
the Builder patterns is used in order to
initialize an object in which I don't
care about most of its properties and I
only care about the some of them and I
do that by initializing the all the
properties I need internal code I had 20
of those in the constructor I'll just
put valid values inside and that's it
and I have a method called build which
return the object I need so far it's
very simple now for every parameter I
want to update or change in my test I'll
create a method usually called with
something with name will change only the
name remember when I'll call build it
will use that new name inside my class
and with the reputation will change on
the delimitation I have one for each and
every property and then I can write this
code create me a new user with the
reputation 10 and the rest of the
properties I don't care about as long as
they're valid and that's it and I get
two things of the views in the Builder
pattern it's very useful for Big Data
classes when I have parameters either as
input or initialization that has a lot
of properties and that way I'll write
less
but I don't need all the parameters I'm
not using and when someone comes and
read my test and they send exactly what
I care about and what I don't he sees
that and says okay this test has
something to do with reputation not name
so I don't need to initialize the whole
class I do that in the background inside
my builder and it will make your life
easier the second pattern a tool called
Auto marking container auto mocking
container and you can find a very good
blog post on one of the speaker called
the maximun is essentially hardly seen
another tool called inversion of control
container you see heard about IOC is a
class yeah container and that will
create another class but the class I
care about and it will create that class
with all the depend its dependencies
automatically and then Auto marking
container will create that class with
all the properties all the dependencies
faked automatically and I can show you
in code because I notice that people
once you start debugging then you really
understand this is the test form
remember that one with all the
initialization and this is the test but
something if you look in the
initialization the setup you'll notice
something most of the fake objects I'm
creating I just need them in order to
create my service and that's it I just
need something to pass in the parameters
I don't do anything with them other than
that so instead of writing this test I
can write the same code with them Auto
mocking container using auto fake that's
an atomic on mocking container which use
auto and IOC container and
basically I'll just care sub get the
fake catcher which I need in order to
set a behavior on it I wanted to for an
exception and I just want to return it
from F X 8'o and then I'll call the
automation container and tell them give
me a real class with whatever you have
and if I'll run this you'll see what I
mean instead of calling new with the
constructor with all the parameters
because we use dependency injection and
we want to pass all the parameters for
the constructor I'll call the automark
in container dot resolve in this case
and if you go to the constructor of this
class hopefully which I didn't put a
breakpoint so they go back to the
drawing board so going back to the
constructor of that class I can notice
that each and every one of them of those
dependencies was in fact faked
automatically so I get a fake object
that I didn't need to declare and if
that constructor will change with more
dependencies that I don't care about in
that test I'll get them as well
automatically and I don't need to update
my test over and over again and that is
a cool thing to use no one usually talk
about Auto mark in containers and
somehow confirm ok I have them built in
as well and you should use them because
your code becomes so much simpler
instead of doing all of this I ended up
just declaring the fake object I do care
about and getting the class back out and
I don't need initialization splitted
between methods and everything becomes
single so this is auto mark in
containers moving on let's talk about
the solutions assert is the thing that
come in the end of the test right for
example right here can you spot a
problem in my test five lines and I
managed to do something wrong anyone
else any idea what I did wrong how about
now what is wrong with this test
two men yourself you testing too many
things right there is a rule called one
assert pair testable right anyone ever
heard about the one assault level test
well one a subtle test whoo sorry which
means that you only have one assault in
each test the reason being is that
otherwise the test will be very complex
and there's also technical reason to do
that and so on
it means that if I have to assert in my
test I have to test right wrong this is
actually I find it to be insane in that
because if you look at this test
how many things I'm testing here there
are two assert but I'm testing one thing
I'm testing the result of some operation
and that result actually is has two
properties one of them is ID and the
other one is content but I'm testing one
thing there's no point in having to test
for this but there is a problem here
because the way a certain walk in J unit
and unit X unit all of those is that if
the assertion is wrong you will get an
exception form and the test will fail
which is good but the bad thing is that
you have no clue about the other asserts
you don't know what happens with this
line with the second line over here if
the first line fails now it's completely
different failure if the ID is wrong but
the content is right from the failure if
both of them are wrong and a gotten
different message and I want this
information because it will make my job
easier easier to maintain
now unfortunately jail it started with
those exceptions idea for an exception
form assertion and everybody follow suit
because it's easy it's very easy to form
an exception you can write your own
assertion library just for it inception
whenever it's false put it a nice
message and I understand the problem and
we did that because usually the guy that
running the test is not the same one is
that unit testing framework we can run
unit s1 within Visual Studio command
line whatever resharper if you use it
and you want to decouple the
implementation of your meters from the
run oh but it's not necessarily the way
to go because there is a programming
language called C++ where they don't for
exceptions on assertion they just write
it down and in the end of the test
tell you about all the failures together
exactly
what I want unfortunately no one has did
that in dotnet Java and so on and so I
ended up with writing my own code to do
that basically what happens here is that
I'll take a bunch of assertions action
actually it's not even assertions run
them in a loop catch all the exceptions
of a hill and then fold them together as
one exception in the end and you can use
this code it's very simple to use this
code it looks something like this
I have two asserts tell me about all the
failures I call that assert all when I
wrote it back then and I was very happy
to find out that and you need the latest
version and in it free has implemented
the same capability but then unit you
can do a certain multiple from now in
the new version which is cool because we
were missing this capability but it's
just a band-aid to fix the real problem
we should not have own assertions to
begin with we should have just written
it somewhere and then tell us all the
problems but that one is not going away
out apparently and generally do the same
and you can see it from journey
documentation although they missed the
point a bit because you can once you get
assert all you tend to write a lot of
code and this is not readable or useful
but a unit 5 the latest version of doing
it has the same capability and if you
look at the code it's about the same as
the code I showed you before run
everything in a loop store all those all
the exceptions you get and then found
them in the end which is cool you should
use those capabilities but you should
not abuse them which means that you
should still test only one thing just
because you can doesn't mean you should
and so on now quick question what is the
difference between those two very
trivial assertions because I'm testing
the the two plus two equals five which
is wrong but there's a big difference
between those two very important one
anyone can spot the difference
exactly yes in all the j-unit derivative
well almost so Google test doesn't do
that we expect something we expect the
expected value to be on the left and the
actual value whatever I got out of my
test to be on the right that the way it
was originally a unit and it means that
when I get an arrow when the test fails
I'll get two different messages one will
say you expected five but God phoned the
other one will say you expected for but
got five obviously this is a trivial
example in your code you will probably
get confused if you put them the other
way around now I think it should have
been the other way around because
usually we say two plus two equal four
not four equals two plus two this is
weird and most developers starting or
some developer starting with the unit
testing will write them that way around
because makes more sense and and then
you get the better whole message you
don't understand that you will see the
code and say oh I missed that and what
about this time another another
difference what is the difference
between using our equal to is true and
again the answer is the error message
because while I get a good error message
out of not equal with is true I will
only get no it's false and again it
means that I'll probably need to debug
my test now and I don't want to do that
because I could get oh I could have
gotten all the information for my test
but using is true should have been the
right way to you go because as a
developer I find the other one there is
sure to be more hittable understandable
and more intuitive
I want to write code I want to tell you
in my code exactly what I want and
you'll do whatever you need right that
is not my job the framework should do
that and their framework that will do
that for you unfortunately there are in
C++ so I got something in dotnet and but
it was awhile ago and I'll talk about
that so assertions there's a lot of
assertion it's how to find the right one
and the right assertion will give you a
good home message while the wrong one
won't
there's the parameter confusion whether
to use the left of the right and then I
seen that some unit testing framework
did is that sometimes the expected value
is on the left and sometime on the right
for example if you look for a substring
it will be on the right on Microsoft
Anita's inthermo
doesn't make it a better unit testing
framework just confusing the expected is
on the right side from some of the
assertion on the left for some and
finally depending on what you use they
have additional session you never heard
about for example in ending it you have
streamed a third class and collection
assault class that you should use but
you might have never heard about them
because they are not in their main
assert dot something class and it's all
about getting the right error message so
I hold something called the self helper
because I like to put my name into stuff
and I just use dotnet which has
expressions and was lean and whatever in
order to analyze what's written it he'll
understand that we have an equal and
uses LTR equal in the end and it's as
simple as that and I don't I don't
understand why and unit doesn't do that
because this is the way I want to see my
assertion just make sure that this is
true give me all the all the useful
information you can give me if it fails
and it's very trivial in fact I didn't
read this idea it was written by a guy
in Microsoft for unit testing for
specific framework in which you can give
the actual code you want to check and it
will give you the right assertion
instead unfortunately that's why were
called Silverlight so the code is
unreachable and you can't find it
anymore my code is on github you can
look and if you want to create a dotnet
core version and he'll they just send me
a pull request I'll be happy and there
are additional assertion libraries that
will help you give make your job easier
such as fluent assertion in dotnet and
should Lee in dotnet and there's ham
crust in Java and will enable you to
write better sessions and even SLE
things that you can't assert with plain
old unit testing framework for example
here I'm asserting that those two
customers has the same properties
excluding the customer ID and you can't
do that properly with an unit in fact
when you call a cell Tirico for two
objects it won't check whether or not
they'll compare to one another it will
run dot equal in dotnet it means usually
that it will check the references and
you get an error message so fluent
assertion should Lee will make your job
easier as well let's talk about test
organization we talked about arrange act
assert right but when you start to write
unit tests there are additional problem
you need to think about for example how
do I call my test what is the name of
the test this is something books have
been written about that one of the
speaker called wash-off has invented a
way to call his tests which are used to
this day and google it and you'll find
it that's one thing you can do triple a
you can mess up triple a as I said
before what should you test you know I
have this bunch of code this huge pile
of code what is the unit no one has ever
defined what is a unit in unit test we
know the properties of a unit test
should be first isolated so on so on but
no one has defined something that you
can take a code and say this is the unit
no one knows it changes from project to
project and how do I not write
complicated tests and again those
problems developers has been thinking
about those problems since 2003 were
genuine it first came out and one such
the consultant called Dan knows ever
heard about the nose invented something
called BDD but he didn't I don't think
he meant to invent the ever diamond
development just wanted to make DES
Levin development and more consign
science define what's the unit is what
you should test what you should perform
and so on and BDD be ever driven
development essentially use a bunch of
tools derivative of cucumber from Ruby
and then Java spec flow in dotnet which
has two files each test is combined from
at least two files one is the
specifications written in semi human
readable way so you can't really mess up
because otherwise something it doesn't
make sense
and the code that runs those
specifications and the specification
looks something like this
the thing that top is just the
description on white what you care about
is the given when then also known as
Gail Kim syntax given that I have been
done this thing and that thing and then
I do this thing that's what I expect to
happen and while ago I was in a project
where we used that capability here we go
and we've written a bunch of scenarios
with given when then and you can read
them you don't even need to know what
the project was about but you can
understand right that they have a
compiled solution in Visual Studio we
were running at the Visual Studio
extension and the project is so-and-so
and I'm compiling that project then one
test should run very readable and anyone
can read it even your product manager
and that's a good thing because that way
you can tell you whether or not you
doing the right thing or you're testing
something completely wrong and then I
have a bunch of action here behind with
attributes or so on to one actual code
for those specifications now I've been
using those bdd framework which well
firstly they were intended in order to
test requirements and to end scenarios
sonali test acceptance as integration
tests to write unit tests because no one
it doesn't really care what you run here
so you can define your unit tests in the
same way with specification that a
different developer can read and
understand but it's a bit of a pain
because you need to maintain two
different files you need to maintain the
specification file and you need to
maintain their actual code behind but
luckily for us there are a bunch of
tools I know of one in dotnet Cole BDD
Phi and this is spec flow sorry we defy
we did a file essentially let me write
the specification in code so I have only
one file for the specification and
running those specifications it's
written in a very concise and easy way
to write to read and improve but the
cool thing about BDD Phi
and I this is one of the api's and it
discovers the steps the specification
from the test method you see it begins
with given when then automatically and
it has a fluent API as well and once I
read those tests and run them then I'll
get the scenario it will write as a
knowledge that I can show my customer
product manager or just for me and if
all right horrible stuff here then I
won't be able to read it and now rename
my method as well and this is cool and
the cool thing is that it also created
an HTML kind of file that I can put on
my source control in my build server and
show everyone and now we understand
exactly what I've been doing and what
failed without reading the code but the
real plus side here is that the tests
become more visible and I get guidance
along the way this is a simple unities
it's not that difficult essentially I
have two files in this size and I set a
bunch of things and when I try to lock
something and I'm over the amount of
space I'm allowed to use then I should
delete those files and that's not nice
this is the same test using VD defy
fluent interface given that I'm out of
storage and there are other log files in
this size and I write a new log message
then all the log files are deleted now
writing this test
I didn't think what I'm testing what I'm
doing I just told you what I'm doing and
well the code accordingly and if I'll
run this thing as well we can see the
scenario and we can verify that I'm
actually it actually makes sense as well
and everyone can read it and it will
make me it will force me to work in a
specific structure very good structure
now in the Java well very spoke that
does the same thing write some code and
you get the specification out of it and
no one said it has to be requirements it
can be whatever you want so we can write
unit tests using those frameworks as
well
so this is that's best structure
basically and good for us let's talk
about test execution once you start
writing unit tests you'll end up with a
lot of unit tests and I offer you that
you have a build server as well that
will run those unit tests on every
commit and you should run all your tests
on every commit as well but the motives
you have running all the tests take more
and more and more time and if you have
integration tests as well which tend to
run a few seconds and not less than a
second that time adds up to a few
minutes or even an hour in one project
we are the three thousand tests they
will run for fifteen minutes
I don't want to run 15 minutes worth of
tests every time I make a change unless
I want to grab a cup of coffee in
between and have a good excuse
I want to run only the relevant tests to
that change and that's it and there's a
bunch of tools that will help me do that
those tools I call them continuous tests
tools those tools basically our coverage
tools that can know which test relates
to which part of your code and when you
change your code only the tests that
affect that piece of code will run okay
question No so doc Carville from Jade
brain will do that and Visual Studio
2017 onwards if you lucky enough to have
their Enterprise Edition you have
something that calls that is called live
unit test that will do that as well
it will run coverage and know exactly
what code relates to what part of your
code and when you change your code it
will run only the test you want to in
the background so you need a few
processors on your machine but other
than that I said but the first one that
actually got it right was unconscious it
has a lot of capabilities and if your
project is not reveal you might want to
check it out as well and that book which
I used to walk there have something as
well called test runner that will do the
same thing and what is the same thing
here we go let's look at my asset helper
their social library from before now a
cert helper is has a lot of classes in
four different desserts and I have right
now 553 tests here and once I run
coverage this is dockable
from there JetBrains it knows exactly
which tests run six Tests past four heel
and five tests class food air and so on
now if i'll make a small change a
breaking change in my code I'll just
change that save and compile I can go
and continue doing something more tests
did you see that or was it too quick and
my tests will run in the background
let's do that again
oh just two magnification as well and
when I compile again it will recognize
that only those tests well affected and
run only them and that way doesn't
matter how many tests I have only the
tests that are affected by that change
in my code will run again and there are
a bunch of tools most of them commercial
but not all of them if you already have
the shopwell tools license of sweet or
you have that capabilities if you have
issues to do enterprise you have that
capability if you buy in crunch you have
that capability and so on and in doclet
code there's a new tool that will do
that as well in Java something called
Intelli tests will do that for you every
compilations will run the tests for you
all of them started form a project can't
back the one that invented essentially
test let me develop indicated something
called j-unit max that will run on the
tests on every compilation and all of
them do exactly that and then enable us
to write to one only the tests that are
affected by the change continuously in
the background like a small server now
you should have a machine with a few
calls to spell in order to do that but
you can continue on writing your code
and the test will continue running in
the back
so what did we have you we talked about
a bunch of things we talked about
arranging your tests well you should use
things like the Builder pattern and auto
marking containers if you never use
those you should they will help you
write better tests easily and in
assertions you might consider using
multiple results now that we have them
write your own there's the code you'll
have you'll have the slides probably
sent to you and you can check them out
or just Google for our Soto and you'll
find my blog post as well and all the
third-party assertion libraries might
help you as well and test structure you
could use BDD to write unit tests no one
said you shouldn't and you can use the
in code BDD I don't have a better name
for those whether you write your code be
the digital to write in a test and
finally continuous testing they're a
bunch of tools here there's a tab
McConnell and Carvel dot cover and
crunch live unit testing Visual Studio
Enterprise infinite testing Java this
new thing called forgot his name Cove
Cove let freely available that you can
use in dotnet call and get continuous
testing because sort of and all of them
will make your life easier and help you
write well a good unit test and will
give you guidance and ruler once you
write a few tests other people will
follow suit because the first test is
hard but once you have a bunch of tests
in a specific area of your code the next
person in line could be you tomorrow
will just copy the same ideas to the
next test and show and slowly but surely
all your code base will become exactly
what you want it to be very uniformly
and very easy to maintain well thank you
for listening if you have any questions
I'll be happy to answer yes
yes yeah III didn't well this is a
mostly doclet you're right the ability
tools for C++ there's even cucumber C++
by the way but food into the communities
yet it listen antennas but catch catches
an excellent Unitarian from in fact I
think that sketch is not an X unit
Islamic it has other ideas it has
sections and a singular self what I did
without net is done in catch
automatically if you walk in C++ you
should use catch in my belief because it
will guide you to the right direction
and it will help you avoid most of the
things I showed you in this session
unfortunately I couldn't find a good way
to move those ideas into dotnet yet but
I'm working on it I'm thinking about it
all the time and yeah catch will also
enable you to write BDD like tests and
yeah C++ has a bunch of additional there
in fact unit s in C++ makes more sense
it needs to me then in.net in a way
because the tools keep changing them
people find new ways cool ways to do
things and in not net well we have J
unit will do the same thing all over
again
actually the Masters 10 unit look
exactly the same
Java quite similar testing G J unit look
about the same only C++ people trying
stuff they were used to that I guess and
so we get to new ideas as well and my
first blow outside cause by the way is
about catch and I'm talking about that
this one anything else okay
yeah I think I've did fund something
in.net mutation testing a tool I didn't
talk about the end mutation testing is
although I can check where I was in my
code using coverage it doesn't
necessarily mean I'm actually testing
everything there I just passed through
that piece of code and mutation testing
will change my production code in order
to make sure that I have a test that
tests that specific area problem with
mutation testing it takes a lot of time
because you have a lot of branches to
follow you need to change your code if
something was fall changed it to true
numbers and so on
and now do not know etc and there is a
tool in dotnet I think if you google for
that
I don't remember its name but it's it
takes forever to run the tests that's
the problem you don't mind you have four
you have a lot of time to drink coffee
yeah yeah mutation testing is a very
interesting idea and if you manage to
create the right suite of tests you will
be very beneficial to you and if you're
willing to allow it to run either
nightly or something like that then
you'll find places in which you missing
tests because it will change your code
and check whether or not in each change
your test will fail and that's a good
idea to edit to the session by the way
but it's a whole session all to itself
you should look it up because with
testing testing should be done right
unless you want to wait a lot yeah
anything else well thank you very much
well
[Applause]